mcmurtry is with us by the way full
disclosure his partner lynn wood
i have recently retained as one of my
personal lawyers
i consider you guys charles harder the
best in the business
uh tell us about this case in particular
well sean thanks for having me on i mean
this case was cnn and
the retweet uh that that came out
recently
uh talking about the settlement or
characterizing the settlement i think
was a big mistake
on cnn's part i don't think brian
stelter should have been commenting on
it
i think it showed poor judgment on his
behalf to do so
clearly he doesn't have any idea what
the terms of the settlement are
yet he showed some poor judgment and and
commenting you know on it
not knowing what he was really talking
about i really
sure yeah i i didn't mean to interrupt
you i've known lynnwood since the
richard jewel case i was in atlanta
in that case i was one of the few people
that didn't rush to judgment
and i taught me a valuable lesson in my
career
um i'm honored that he's i've been able
to retain him as my own personal
attorney
he's great as what he at what he does uh
i know one thing about linwood
there's those saying oh it's a nominal
son i don't some i don't believe that
for a second
i and i know you can't disclose it but i
know lynn wood
lynnwood wouldn't settle for a nominal
sum ever under any circumstances you
think i might be in the right is my
am i over the target
well as you said i can't really comment
and we did agree with cnn and the
washington post not to characterize the
settlement but i know lynn as well
he's a fabulous lawyer and he does great
work and it's a pleasure to work with
him
on these cases yeah he does this at a
passion what they did to this young man
he this young man handled all this
perfectly
is unconscionable the difference between
me and this young man is he's not a
public figure
this is more of a slam-dunk case than
most people know
and i believe this kid might even be a
billionaire when all said and done
thank you for standing up for this young
man he did not deserve this in any way